all right extremely strange news out of
the alex jones defamation trial as many
of you know the uh jury found for the
plaintiffs in the alex jones defamation
trial for roughly 49 million dollars uh
alex jones text messages that were
obtained by uh plaintiff's attorney mark
bankston during that trial have now been
turned over to the house committee
investigating the january six trump
riots and the story is going to shift
over there to some degree but there's
now a new wrinkle to the case
uh mark bankston the attorney for the
plaintiffs who will hopefully be joining
me on the show very soon to talk about
all of the all of the trial
he revealed to our friend anna casparian
on the young turks that alex jones sent
what appear to be
consensual consexual non-consensual nude
images of his own wife
to roger stone the uh indicted and
pardoned former trump adviser this is
now going from just horrifying to
bizarre
look at this
in the guardian the headline is alex
jones sent nude photo of wife
to roger stone sandy hook lawyer reveals
picture was among cache of messages
inadvertently handed over by infowars
host's lawyer to the opposition legal
team remember this incredible moment
from the trial where it was revealed
that alex jones own attorney
accidentally sent a digital copy of his
entire phone to the opposing council
lawyers for the notorious american
conspiracy theorist alex jones
accidentally gave his legal adversaries
a nude photo of his wife that he had
texted to the conservative political
operative roger stone
the seemingly farcical that i would call
it farcical or kafka-esque the seemingly
farcical but entirely true development
was the latest bit of fallout since one
of the attorneys for a family suing
jones for defamation revealed last week
that jones owned lawyer inadvertently
handed over numerous text messages the
lawyer mark bankston the recipient of
the leak appeared on monday on the young
turks to confirm one of the texting
questions
contained a naked photo of jones wife
sent to stone now since there's been a
commentary from alex jones wife alex
jones wife says she is unaware
and upset her husband sent a nude photo
of her to roger stone so indeed it was
sent
non-consensually what we don't know is
whether the picture itself was
non-consensual there's a little bit of a
gray area
alex jones might have taken the picture
consensually and sent it to roger stone
without consent or even the existence of
the picture itself might be
non-consensual uh let's take a listen to
the
clip from mark bankston speaking to uh
the young turks mr jones said that there
was an intimate photo of his wife on the
phone that i can also confirm that's
true and i normally wouldn't talk about
that in public um but there is a public
interest angle into this is that i'm a
little concerned about it because that
intimate photo was sent to roger stone
and i don't know if that was consensual
and if it wasn't consensual and mrs wolf
jones should know about that and there
might be something that needs to be done
about that then again it could be
totally consensual but when i see that
and i don't see any indication that it
was
i'm concerned something might not be on
the up and up with that there are
certainly laws in certain states about
that yeah and in fact we've since found
out thanks to the uh cl comment
from erica wolf jones she was not aware
of the exchange and was upset about the
disclosure
the wife of conservative radio host alex
jones told insider tuesday she was
unaware her husband sent a nude photo of
her former of her to former donald trump
advisor roger stone
um
we're gonna try to get mark bankston on
the show very very soon to talk about i
think that there are probably a dozen
other
bizarre
major interesting stories
underneath what is currently publicly
known about this and it's so strange to
think i've told the story before back
when i met alex jones years ago
at a talk radio event called the
talker's new media seminar
he really first of all his physical
appearance was far more normal he also
spoke far more normally
in what was not like an on-air capacity
he was still the wacky guy on air
but behind the scenes we were just
chatting and i was on the outskirts of
this small group of four people who were
who were chatting i had not met him
before
he seemed to even acknowledge
the way that he's perceived saying after
the speech he gave
you know i could have really freaked him
out if i'd wanted to sort of like
acknowledging that he toned down his
character because it was sort of like an
industry event or whatever
now every video of alex jones outside of
his show whether it's someone going up
to him on the street or the testimony
that he gave under oath during the trial
that just completed
it seems as though there is now really
no difference between the on-air alex
jones and the off-air alex jones and it
is dramatically different than what i
experienced personally
uh i mean i guess at this point it was
like 12 years ago
so i don't know what to make of it but
it wouldn't come as a shock
if indeed there was this predatory
aspect to alex jones as well where he is
non-consensually sending nude pictures
of his wife to people all
extraordinarily bizarre